Ich bin ein Ruhrpott-Junge.
Drogen verkaufen, Anerkennung bekommen.
Und das war für mich der Nährboden, wo ich gesagt habe: "Boah geil, jetzt bin ich wer! Jetzt gehöre ich dazu!"
Ausm Auto rausgezogen, Decke übern Kopf, weg war ich!
Ich hatte meinen ersten Ausgang mit 'nem Beamten gehabt.
Zum ersten Mal wahrgenommen im Café: Jeder war aufm Smartphone!
Immer: "Oh mein Gott, ich tu und da tut sich nix mehr obwohl ich Low Carb ernähre!" und da ist der Fehler.
(Kiki: Genau!)
Ist leider Fakt Leute: Man hat immer Vorurteile!
Wollen wir uns nichts vormachen, manche Männer spielen ja auch gerne den Macho!
Und jetzt den vierten, komm!
Kiki! SInd wir Macher oder Kacker? 12!
(Kiki: Macher!)
Ach, von hier hoch?
(Sharo: Ja!)
Achso jetzt zieht's!
Hi zusammen! Heute machen wir Burger und dafür habe ich einen ganz besonderen Gast:
Er kocht auch gerne, macht aber auch sehr gerne ein bisschen Fitness.
Ich begrüße heute in meiner Küche Sharo von Beast Kitchen!
(Sharo: *lacht*)
Wir sind beide ein bisschen aufgeregt, geben wir's zu!
Hallo liebe Kiki erstmal, Hallo Leute!
Ich bin tierisch aufgeregt! Danke, dass ich hier in deiner Küche stehen darf,
ist mir eine Ehre! Ich freue mich.
(Kiki: Sehr gerne!)
Wir machen richtig leckere Burger heute!
(Sharo: Burger! Ich liebe Burger!)
Ich habe eine Schwäche für Burger. Eine sehr große Schwäche für Burger, vor allem für Fleisch!
Was für Burger machen wir denn?
(Kiki: Wir machen Beef Burger mit selbstgemachten Buns.)
Das Rezept verlinke ich euch aber in die Infobox weil das habe ich einfach gestern vorbereitet.
Darauf ein bisschen Camembert, Preiselbeeren und einfach gucken, wonach uns ist!
Hört sich außergewöhnlich an. Diese Kombination von Burger muss ich dir gestehen habe ich noch nicht gegessen.
Ah okay, krass!
(Sharo: Umso mehr freue ich mich da drauf!)
Okay, cool! Bevor wir starten Sharo erzähl mal in 2-3 Sätzen wer du bist und was du machst.
Ich glaube, du kannst dich selber am allerbesten vorstellen.
Also ich bin der Sharo, ich bin 36 Jahre alt. Ich bin beruflich Fitnesstrainer.
Als Fitnesstrainer musst du dich automatisch auch viel mit Lebensmitteln befassen und so kam auch meine Leidenschaft zum Kochen.
Ja und ich sage immer wieder Kochen ist das neue Feiern!
Ich feier den Spruch!
Und ich werde auf jeden Fall Sharos YouTube-Kanal Beast Kitchen in die Infobox verlinken.
Da hast du auch immer spannende Gäste, geile Rezepte!
(Sharo: Vielen Dank, genau! Ich habe ein Kochformat auf YouTube)
Ein Interview-Kochformat auf YouTube und da lade ich auch immer hin und wieder Gäste ein.
Wir kochen zusammen und unterhalten uns über Gott und die Welt.
Okay, cool! Und so ähnlich machen wir das heute.
Das heißt wir fangen jetzt an..dein Kameramann Tristan ist auch mit dabei.
Genau!
(Kiki: Schwenk doch mal kurz rüber dass er auch mal Hallo sagt!)
Hallöchen!
Und von ihm kam der Vorschlag wir machen ein Relish aus sauren Gurken,
Zwiebeln und...Apfelessig.
(Sharo: Zwiebeln und Apfelessig!)
Und das machen wir jetzt als Erstes.
(Sharo: M-hm!)
Wir haben hier, das war die Fleischpfanne, richtig?
(Kiki: Richtig, genau!)
Kiki, du hast eine tolle Küche. Wie kriege ich da was an?
Einfach hier hin.. Nehmen wir einfach das.
Wow!
Du kochst nicht mit Induktion habe ich gesehen.
(Sharo: Nein, auf Gas!)
Auf Gas. Was findest du daran besser?
Ich liebe die Flamme! Also schau mal: Wir haben angefangen, zu kochen auf Feuer
ich sehe da Feuer und das fasziniert mich einfach.
(Kiki: Ja!)
(Hamza: Also ich glaube auch viele Libanesen kochen mit Gas!)
Ja..also hier in Deutschland ist das eher wenig sage ich mal.
Da musst ja extra umbauen oder extra eine Gasleitung für haben.
Aber wenn die Leute die Möglichkeit dafür haben, so wie ich das aus meinem Familien- und Bekanntenkreis kenne, greifen die auf Gas zurück.
Und ich finde so die Flamme, wenn du die Pfanne schwenkst, weißt du..
(Kiki: Ist ein anderes Feeling!)
Ja, ja!
(Kiki: Auf jeden Fall!)
Sharo du hast mir gesagt ich darf dich alles fragen heute.
(Sharo: Du darfst mich alles fragen.)
Also ich muss kein Blatt vor den Mund nehmen.
(Sharo: Nein, nein.)
Deswegen habe ich gedacht, wir quatschen jetzt mal ein bisschen-
(Hamza: Ich glaub der kann's auch aushalten!)
Ja, ich glaube auch!
(Sharo: *lacht)
Es kann nur sein, dass im Laufe der Zeit ich immer kleiner werde und hier unter der Küche ende!)
(Kiki: Ach Quatsch!)
Wenn man dich so sieht, denkt man: "Okay, Sharo, der gerne kocht"..
Daran sieht man übrigens auch wieder: Kochen verbindet!
(Sharo: Absolut!)
Also wir sind gerade das beste Beispiel dafür, wir kochen einfach in einer gemütlichen Runde.
Wir sind 2 unterschiedlich Personen.
(Kiki: Ja!)
Sage ich mal, ja. Wir verkehren glaube ich in unterschiedlichen Kreisen.
Ja und dennoch verbindet uns..wir haben eine Gemeinsamkeit.
Eine große Gemeinsamkeit: das Kochen!
Richtig. Und das finde ich eben so geil, dass wir jetzt hier stehen und einfach was kochen!
Ich bin im Libanon geboren und seit '86 leben meine Eltern hier.
Ah, okay!
(Sharo: Ja, überwiegend im Ruhrgebiet.)
Ich sag eigentlich auch immer: Ich komme aus dem Ruhrgebiet, ich bin ein Ruhrpott-Junge.
Ich hab leider mein Land noch nicht gesehen.
Libanon hab ich leider noch nicht gesehen. Das war immer begleitet von politischen Spannungen wenn ich runter fliegen wollte.
Und ich werd's hoffentlich nochmal nachholen aber wenn mich jemand fragt, wo ich herkomme, sage ich immer "Ausm Ruhrpott".
Okay. Ja schade, dass du noch nie da warst.
(Sharo: Ja.)
Vermisst du's denn oder hast du Sehnsucht?
(Sharo: Ich kann's nicht vermissen weil ich das nicht kenne:)
Okay, richtig.
(Sharo: Leider Gottes, ja. Und natürlich sind da meine Wurzeln.)
Ich sehne mich schon danach und ich hab da auch wirklich oft vorgehabt, da runter zu fliegen und immer wieder hieß es:
"Nein jetzt nicht! Politische Spannungen, politische Spannungen!" und ich hoffe das legt sich.
So, wir haben jetzt hier in der Pfanne ein bisschen Speiseöl.
Da kommen die Gurken rein, Zwiebel..
Das lassen wir jetzt langsam vor sich her köcheln.
Wir löschen das Ganze gleich mit Apfelessig, würzen das Ganze mit Salz und Zucker und dann..
Perfekt!
(Sharo: So, Kochlöffel liebe Kiki!)
Kochlöffel, ja.. Hier, bitte!
(Sharo: Dankeschön!)
Wie stelle ich den jetzt nochmal höher? Bevor wir anfangen?
Also einfach hier drücken und dann kannst du.. an diesem..
(Sharo: Ah okay, okay!)
Da musst du vorher eine App dafür studieren!
(Kiki: *lacht*)
Ja Sharo, du bist ja mehr oder weniger jetzt echt eine Vorbildfunktion
weil auf deinem Kanal Beast Kitchen, da kochst du wirklich viel, da machst du viel...
Bekommst du viele Fotos auch von den nachgemachten Gerichten?
Ja, ich krieg wirklich immer wieder Stories und das Schöne ist auch wer mir die Stories schickt:
Meistens sind das auch so richtige Bullemänner und dann: "Hier, guck mal was ich gezaubert habe, wie geil! Meine Frau, meine Kinder, die sind so mega happy!"
Und das finde ich einfach toll!
Wir wollen uns auch nichts vormachen: Manche Männer spielen ja gerne den Macho
und sagen so: "Boah nee, in der Küche hab ich nix verloren, nur die Frau rein!"
Und das ist völliger Bullshit, das sehe ich auch immer wieder an meiner Community.
Ja und.. Ihr Männer, ran an die Küche, nehmt euch den Kochlöffel!
Ihr begeistert die Frauen, ihr bringt eine Harmonie nach Hause rein, das ist unglaublich!
Auf jeden Fall! Ist ja auch - Klischees sind sowieso out, ne? Ich finde Männer können genauso gut kochen wie Frauen.
Ganz kurz! Ganz kurz, ganz kurz:
Es heißt ja auch der Koch!
Stimmt, ja!
(Hamza: *lacht*)
Und bei uns im Arabischen auch "al tabakh"! Wie heißt das im Türkischen?
Ähm..
(Sharo: Ist das auch ein männlicher oder weiblicher Artikel?)
Ich überlege grade, im Türkischen gibt's keine männlichen und weiblichen Artikel, gibt's keine Gender.
Okay aber du weißt was ich meine Hamza, ja?
Und es heißt ja auch "der Koch" von daher: Männer ran da!
(Kiki: Männer ran an den Herd!)
(Hamza: Also ich mach trotzdem nix!)
Hamza macht trotzdem nix! Der muss auch noch ein paar Videos von dir gucken!
Schreibt das mal in die Kommentare rein wenn ihr mal Hamza hinter der Küche sehen wollt.
Und vielleicht hält mal die Kiki die Cam, das wär auch interessant!
Auf jeden Fall! Da würde ich mich einmal zurücklehnen, wär für mich auch ganz geil!
(Hamza: Und dann verbrennt die Küche!)
Neein!
Ja und du warst in deiner Vergangenheit - um jetzt mal von der Vergangenheit ein bisschen zu erzählen -
ich weiß das weil ich mir ein Interview angeguckt habe..
(Sharo: Und jetzt wird's mir warm!)
Hau raus!
(Kiki: Wir lüften gleich ein bisschen, nein!)
Nein, alles gut!
(Kiki: Du warst tatsächlich im Knast.)
Was ist der Grund dafür kurz und knapp?
Kurz und knapp: Ich hab Scheiße gebaut.
Ich musste mir eine Zeit lang in meinem Leben nicht weiter zu helfen. Ich habe leider einen falschen Weg eingegangen und habe mit BTM gehandelt.
Okay, was ist das?
(Sharo: Betäubungsmittel.)
Okay, mhm.
(Sharo: Ich hab - kann ich das so sagen?)
Du kannst alles sagen, was du willst!
(Sharo: Okay, ich hab Gras verkauft.)
Okay, dann schon eher verstanden. Wenn man nicht so in der Materie ist..
Wie viele Jahre hast du das gemacht?
Oh, es hat mich sehr lange begleitet.
Ich sag's mal so: ich fange mal von vorne an. Weil du sagst gerade "kurz und knapp halten". Das schaffe ich nicht kurz und knapp!
Ich bin relativ früh Vater geworden.
Damals konnte ich schwer mit meinen Eltern kommunizieren über dieses Thema und ich wusste mir auch nicht weiter zu helfen.
Einfach nur Flucht: Ich hab 'nen Rucksack zusammengepackt, bin raus aus meinem Elternhaus in die weite Welt hinaus
und bin so auf die schiefe Bahn gekommen und das hat sich wirklich lange gezogen.
Ich hab's erstmal gemacht um meinen Hunger zu stillen sage ich mal.
Und irgendwann mal habe ich durch dieses ganze Drogen verkaufen Anerkennung bekommen.
Und das war für mich der Nährboden, wo ich gesagt habe: "Boah geil, jetzt bin ich wer. Jetzt gehöre ich dazu!"
Und die ganzen schönen Autos und so weiter und so fort.. Ja, bis zu dem Tag, an wo's geknallt hat.
Ja, der Tag, an dem du quasi gepackt wurdest.
(Sharo: Genau.)
Was war das für ein Moment, wo warst du da gerade?
Ohh..ich bin morgens rausgegangen zum - einen Moment, ich mach einmal, ja?
Ja klar! Soll ich's einfach reinpacken?
(Sharo: M-hm.)
Okay, wir machen jetzt ein bisschen Zucker hier rein..
(Kiki: Mhm!)
Sehr gut, das dürfte langen.
(Kiki: Das reicht, okay.)
Genau. Und dann löschen wir das Ganze nochmal mit Apfelessig.
Dann reduziert sich das irgendwann und wird glaub ich so ein bisschen weich, ne?
(Sharo: Genau, dann wird das matschig!)
(Sharo: Genau, dann kann das langsam vor sich her köcheln.)
So, nochmal. Wo waren wir stehengeblieben?
(Kiki: Äh der Moment, an dem du dann erwischt wurdest.)
Genau, der Moment, an dem ich erwischt wurde. Was habe ich gemacht?
Ich bin morgens - erst mal: Komischerweise bin ich damals um 7h morgens aus dem Haus gegangen.
Und sonst immer?
(Sharo: So gegen 10h.)
Ich hatte da einen Arzttermin und bin um 7h aus dem Haus gegangen und da habe ich schon gemerkt: Da stimmt was nicht!
Ich bin da zum Arzt, bin wieder nach hause gekommen und dann wurde ich festgenommen.
Okay. Waren die dann bei dir in der Wohnung, vor der Tür? Wie war das?
Die hatten - das ist krass. Ich weiß nicht, ob das für deinen Channel ist!
Hau ruhig raus!
(Sharo: Ich hau einfach raus und wenn ihr das veröffentlicht,)
dann ist es mir egal! Also das war wirklich eine krasse Nummer.
Die haben sich so auf den Dächern verschanzt, in den Büschen und überall.
Und ich wollte parken und ich hab über einem Bäcker gewohnt
Und zu dem Zeitpunkt - das war dann 11-12h wo ich dann ankam -
normalerweise ist dann richtig Betrieb und an dem Tag: tote Hose! Parkplatz leer!
Ich hab geparkt und dann sehe ich: da kommt ein Mercedes Vito mit Kuhfänger.
Ich so: Will der anhalten? Hä?
Der fährt schneller, will er anhalten? Und dann bumm, ist er mir in's Auto reingefahren.
Krass!
(Sharo: Ja, der ist mir ins Auto reingefahren)
und dann hab ich noch im Rückspiegel wahrgenommen, wie die sich abgeseilt haben. Ja und dann ging's ruck-zuck.
Ausm Auto rausgezogen, Decke übern Kopf und weg war ich!
(Kiki: Ach krass!)
Decke übern Kopf und du bist dann wo gelandet?
Im Polizeipräsidium!
(Kiki: Ahja okay!)
Ach krass!
(Sharo: Ja, ja!)
Und als die dann reingefahren sind ins Auto, hätten die dich auch anders erwischen können?
Dass du, weiß ich nicht...
Also ich sag mal so: Hätten die bei mir angeklopft und gesagt "Es liegt grad 'n Haftbefehl vor, komm mit!"
ich wär auch mitgekommen.
(Kiki: Ja, klar.)
Ich weiß ich sehe auch gefährlich aus aufgrund meines Erscheinungsbildes aber ich bin nicht der Typ Mensch, wie du mich durch deine Augen wahrnimmst.
Und das war auch immer so ein Punkt in meinem Leben wo ich immer meine Schwierigkeiten mit hatte.
Ich weiß ich sehe jetzt nicht grad so auf den ersten Blick sympathisch aus. Man könnte denken: "Ach, der ist von ner Diskothek der Türsteher"
oder aus irgendeinem Rockerclub sage ich mal. Aber völliger Bullshit.
Ich weiß ich hab Scheiße gebaut in meinem Leben
aber...ich weiß nicht, wie ich das sagen soll. Ich hab wirklich das Herz am rechten Fleck.
Ich hab mir damals nicht anders zu helfen gewusst.
Ich bin diesen falschen Weg gegangen aber ich bin nicht in dieses Extreme reingegangen.
Also irgendwann hatte ich so ein bisschen - wie sagt man? Ahsas, Gefühle. So: Stopp!
Bis hierhin reicht's.
(Kiki: Ja.)
Und so kam's, ja.
Also schön, dass du so offen bist! Das ist glaub ich nicht selbstverständlich.
Mir wird grad richtig warm! *lacht*
(Kiki: Ja, also alles gut!)
Wenn äh..
(Sharo: Nein, alles gut!)
(Hamza: Man merkt auch diese Reue bei dir. Man merkt das, man hört das irgendwie raus.)
Ja..also, ich hätt mir auch wirklich gern 'nen anderen Weg gewünscht.
So ist das nicht, ja. Ich hätt mir gern wirklich 'nen anderen Weg gewünscht.
Zu der Zeit, wo das alles so angefangen hat.. ich war nicht soweit,
auch nicht meine Eltern. Ich will denen nicht die Schuld geben, um Gottes willen!
Nicht falsch verstehen, ich gebe nicht meinen Eltern die schuld.
Wir waren damals einfach nicht so weit über diese bestimmten Probleme zu kommunizieren.
Mein Fall oder sage ich mal mein Ereignis hat jetzt auch bei uns in der Familie so ein bisschen.. *atmet aus*
Jeder baut Scheiße, ja? Keiner ist fehlerfrei und wichtig ist
wenn jemand Fehler baut, darüber zu reden und gemeinsame Lösungen zu finden.
Und nicht dieses Abschotten weil dann kann's gefährlich ausgehen.
(Kiki: Ja!)
Ja, das - ich bin dann rausgegangen und hab mein eigenes Ding gemacht.
Und es gab da Höhen und Tiefen, das ging auch über Jahre hinweg.
Also ich bin damals bis 19/20 von meinem Elternhaus ausgereist
und irgendwann mal nach 6 Jahren hab ich dann irgendwann erst meine Eltern wieder gesehen.
Ach das erste Mal nach 6 Jahren dann wieder?
Und wie war so die Gefühlslage?
Sehr emotional, sehr emotional. Meine Eltern haben auch so Reue gezeigt,
ich habe Reue gezeigt und wir haben auch hamdulilah Gott sei Dank wieder zueinander gefunden.
Hamdulilah, schön! Und wie lange saßt du insgesamt im Gefängnis?
Insgesamt - also meine Strafe war 7 Jahre, 10 Monate und nach 5 Jahren, 10 Monaten kam ich raus.
Okay. Das heißt seit wievielen Jahren bist zu jetzt wieder draußen?
"Seit wie vielen Jahren bist du draußen?" Seit wie vielen Jahren bin ich draußen? Ich glaub keine 3 Jahre!
Ach krass!
(Sharo: M-hm!)
Also ich dachte die ganze Zeit - ich hab nur ein Interview von dir gesehen -
und ich dachte: "Okay, ist vielleicht 10-15 Jahre her".
Das heißt das ist noch gar nicht so lange her!
Nein, nein. Ist noch ganz frisch.
(Kiki: Krass!)
Wir müssen den Herd anmachen!
(Kiki: Jaja wir machen den Herd an jetzt ohne, dass es einer merkt!)
6?
(Sharo: Ja, lass 6 langsam köcheln. Das ist ausgegangen gerade, ich weiß nicht, warum!)
Ach, alles gut!
Ohhh der Tristan war enttäuscht!
(Kiki: Wieso, warum das denn?)
Tut mir leid, dass wir nicht extra ein neues gekauft haben!
Einer war wirklich mit 'nem Rennrad da! Bis nach Holland aufm Rennrad!
(Hamza: Aber Rennrad ist geil!)
Was für "Ist geil"? Weißt du, wie der Hintern da wehtut?
Und wohin fahrt ihr bei 200k?
Nach Berlin!
(Kiki: Nach Berlin, okay!)
Nach Berlin.
(Hamza: Mitm Fahrrad?)
Mitm Fahrrad, ja. Egal, bei was für einem Wetter.
(Tristan: Also ausm Ruhrgebiet!)
Ausm Ruhrpott, ja!
Und egal bei was für einem Wetter, ne?
Ja!
(Kiki: Iih, so richtig Matschregen und so!)
(Sharo: Egal, das wird geil!)
(Kiki: Hier der Tristan trägt 'ne Brille und die Brille ist dann voller Regen!)
(Hamza: Man merkt du hast Bock drauf!)
Ich hab wirklich Bock Leute!
Es gibt nicht das falsche Wetter, es gibt nur die falsche Kleidung!
(Kiki: Richtig!)
(Tristan: Weiß nicht ob du das auch noch sagst wenn du bei -3° C aufm Fahrrad bist!)
Ich bin das gewohnt bei dem Wetter zu fahren!
(Hamza: Also das heißt jetzt einfach alle abonnieren damit die noch im Winter fahren!)
Wir haben nämlich grad darüber gesprochen! Sharo und Tristan, wer noch?
Also das Beast Kitchen Team, ne?
(Kiki: Das Beast Kitchen Team!)
Das fährt bei 200.000 Abonnenten auf deinem Kanal mit dem Fahrrad nach Berlin!
Egal bei - es kann auch regnen, es kann schneien, es ist scheiß-egal!
Egal was für ne Wetterlage, egal -
(Hamza: Wurde grad auch eingeladen aber ich darf nicht, Kiki hat Nein gesagt!)
(Kiki: Okay, Hamza ist hier so Pantoffelheld!)
Für 1-2 Tage gibst du den doch bestimmt mal ab!
(Kiki: Ach klar, klar!)
(Sharo: So 50-60km, schön bei Regen, Gegenwind, und so! Bergauf..kommt stark!)
(Sharo: *lacht*)
(Kiki: Dann kann er ja ein bisschen die Torten abtrainieren!)
Also daher meine Bitte an die Kikimunity: Einmal unten in der ersten Zeile den Link abchecken
und lasst mal ein kostenloses Abo da. Da sind leckere Gerichte, super interessante Gäste..
vielleicht lädst du mich ja auch mal ein in deine Küche! Dann..
(Sharo: Absolut!)
Ich hab mir auch was überlegt!
(Kiki: Ja?)
Was wir gemeinsam mal machen könnten! Ich bin ja wirklich nicht so der Pro
und du könntest mir oder ich hab mir vorgestellt, ein Format zu machen:
"Kiki bringt Sharo Kochen bei"!
(Kiki: Ah ja!)
So Lifehacks, ja? So..
(Kiki: Ja geil!)
Du hast doch bestimmt so Tricks mit Küchengeräten oder so..
(Kiki: Ja, gibt's immer!)
Da gibt's ja bestimmt tolle Sachen und ich könnte mir das vorstellen, dass du mir das zeigst oder nahe bringst!
Finde ich richtig geil!
(Sharo: Ja?)
Höre ich grad zum ersten Mal, was meint ihr dazu?
Lass doch mal die Leute abstimmen!
(Sharo: Kommentiert mal, sagt mal was dazu!)
Also ich würd's mir wünschen, ich könnt's mir gut vorstellen!
(Kiki: Genau!)
So, ich komm bei dir und du zeigst mir:
"Ey, heute können wir den und den Lifehack, so 3-4 Lifehacks ausprobieren!"
(Kiki: Ja!)
Ja, mir das zeigen und..
(Kiki: Geil, geil!)
Ich lerne was, wir haben Spaß dran und die Leute haben ihr Entertainment!
(Kiki: Auf jeden Fall!)
(Kiki: Das wird unser neues Format!)
Geil!
(Sharo: Ich freu mich drauf!)
(Hamza: Ich will, dass du was backst!)
Ja, hab ich mir auch überlegt!)
Backen hab ich auch noch nicht gemacht!
(Kiki: Du musst mal was backen mit mir zusammen!)
Sharo, wir machen eine Fitness Torte!
(Sharo: Eine Fitness Torte?)
Sollen wir eine Fitness Torte zusammen machen?
(Sharo: Ja oder so geile  Muffins!)
Oder geile - okay sorry! Ich hab nur gedacht -
(Sharo: Alles gut! Nein, nein!)
Wir können ein bisschen philosophieren, vielleicht haben auch die Leute auch noch Vorschläge! Kommentiert mal,
knallt mal die Kommentar voll und...
(Kiki: Auf jeden Fall!)
Wir schauen, wozu wir uns inspirieren lassen!
Also würdest du auch wirklich so richtig Zucker und Butter und naschen..?
Ja, jetzt geht das, ja,ja! Jetzt ist auch die Weihnachtszeit, ja?
Da hab ich überhaupt kein Problem, also in der Winterzeit schlemme ich gerne.
Geil, ja!
(Sharo: Ich brauch das auch in der Winterzeit!)
(Kiki: Dann machen wir das!)
*alle lachen*
Cool!
(Hamza: Was macht ihr jetzt?)
Also wir haben jetzt grad die Patties vorgeformt, wir nehmen immer 130g.
(Sharo: Mhm, so ca. 130g, richtig!)
Genau, das ist übrigens freundliche Unterstützung von Traumkuh!
Da hat der Chef mir höchstpersönlich heute Black Angus Fleisch vorbeigebracht
und ich hab gedacht: "Komm wenn Sharo da ist, dann brauch ich wirklich was Besonderes!"
Nur das Beste hier!
(Sharo: Danke, danke!)
Das ist jetzt auch ungewürzt, das machen wir gleich erst, ne?
(Sharo: Mhm!)
Wie sieht's da drüben aus?
Das sieht gut aus! Wir müssen auch immer ein bisschen Wasser nachschütten
und langsam vor sich her köcheln lassen..
während wir das noch formen. Bis wir fertig sind denk ich dürfte das auch fertig sein.
(Kiki: Und was wir auch schon vorbereitet haben sind die Ofenkartoffeln.)
Da hat der Sharo mir auch einen geilen Tipp gegeben! Hau mal raus für die anderen?
(Sharo: Eigentlich ist das sehr simpel! Erstmal in Spalten schneiden
und dann in kochendes Wasser für 5min legen.)
(Kiki: Genau, entzieht nochmal die Stärke dann!)
(Sharo: Macht die Stärke weg, spült's dann nochmal aus..)
(Sharo: Wir hatten jetzt heute leider kein Reismehl da, sonst könnte man ein bisschen drüberstreuen und dann werden die richtig schön knusprig!)
Aber die sehen jetzt schon gut aus!
(Kiki: Die sehen gut - die sind auch schon fertig, ne?)
Die sind fertig, genau!
Dann würd ich sagen braten wir jetzt die Patties an..genau! Camembert kommt dazu, Preiselbeeren und unser Relish.
M-hm..wir können den Camembert auch schonmal zurechtschneiden, oder?
Ja, den geb ich dir schonmal!
Danke!
(Hamza: Habt ihr Seiten gewechselt?)
(Kiki: Jetzt haben wir kurz einmal..)
Wir haben Seiten gewechselt, genau!)
Ich schneid den Camembert grade damit das gleich flott geht, ja?
(Kiki: Genau!)
Gleich die Patties braten, dann geht das ruck-zuck!
(Kiki: Das muss schnell gehen, genau!)
Das schieb ich jetzt an die Seite, können wir gleich nochmal abschmecken mit dem Salz!
Wieviel Senf?
(Tristan: Mach nach Gefühl!)
So nach Gefühl?
(Sharo: Jaja!)
Aber nicht zu viel, oder? Das schmeckt sonst so ein bisschen..
(Tristan: Das wird so leicht beigefarben wenn du's umrührst und dann ist das gut. Kannst ja auch mal probieren!)
Okay komm Sharo, wir probieren mal!
(Sharo: Jawoll! Deine Löffel waren hier? Ich fühl mich schon fast wie Zuhause!)
Ja, gewöhn dich schonmal hier an unser Format bald!
(Sharo: *lacht*)
Salz haben wir schon drin?
Salz ist drin! Allerdings nicht viel, ich wollt erstmal nicht übertreiben.
Nachsalzen geht auch immer, ne?
(Kiki: Eben, genau!)
Das erinnert mich leicht an diese - Kann man das sagen? - McDonald's Soße, was auf dem Burger drauf ist!)
Was aufm Burger ist, ja stimmt! Schmeckt sehr lecker, find ich richtig geil!
Auf diesem Cheeseburger, weißt du?
(Kiki: Genau, dieses, dieses - Tüpfelchen!)
(Kiki: Dieser kleine, kleine Klecks, den die da drauf machen!)
Daran erinnert mich das! Und was findet ihr, die Leute sollen das mal ausprobieren!
Die Leute sollen das auf jeden Fall ausprobieren! Ich schreib ja sowieso alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben in die Videobeschreibung
und die Credits für das Rezept gehen an Tristan. Also das ist echt cool, hab ich so auch noch nicht gemacht!
Genau, Camembert hast du jetzt geschnitten.
(Sharo: Mhm, Camembert ist geschnitten!)
Dann würd ich sagen einfach die Patties rein. Kein Fett, da ist ja schon genug Fett im Fleisch.
(Sharo: Nee, kein Fett. Auf gar keinen Fall!)
Nochmal zurück zu deiner Haft sag ich mal. GIbt's da auch Leute, die du ins Herz geschlossen hast?
Ich hab bis heute tatsächlich noch mit 3 Leuten Kontakt.
Ah, okay. Sind die draußen schon oder..?
(Sharo: Jaja, die sind draußen auch!)
Grüße Jungs!
(Kiki: Grüße gehen raus unbekannterweise!)
Und was war so das Prägendste, was du für dich jetzt auch fürs spätere Leben mitgenommen hast von der ganzen Geschichte?
Alles! Das Prägendste ist - also der ganze Knast hat mir gezeigt:
Jeder darf Fehler bauen, gar keine Frage. Wichtig ist, das wieder gut zu machen.
Ich hab meine Strafe verbüßt, gar keine Frage. Ich bin auch rausgekommen
und ich war auch erstmal erschreckt, muss ich dir ehrlich sagen.
Ich war erschreckt darüber, wie die Leute so fixiert auf materielle Dinge sind.
Und viele nur noch Smartphone..
Wo ich damals festgenommen wurde, das war im Jahr 2012. Da waren gerade so die Smartphones im Kommen.
(Kiki: Genau, iPhone! iPhone 4..)
Genau und dann war ich 5 Jahre.. iPhone 5 war das!
Ich wurde wirklich 2 Tage glaub ich nach dem Release vom iPhone 5 festgenommen, kann ich mich gut dran erinnern!
Und ich war auch nie der Fan damals zum Zeitpunkt von Smartphones. Auf jeden Fall bin ich dann rausgekommen und ich war wirklich erschreckt!
Ich hatte meinen ersten Ausgang mit 'nem Beamten gehabt.
Und dann saßen wir im Café und ich schwör's dir ungelogen da hab ich das erste Mal wahrgenommen im Café: Jeder war am Smartphone!
(Kiki: Krass, ne?)
Der Beamte sagte zu mir das ist normal geworden aber für mich war das voll erschreckend!
Ich kannte das nicht! Ich kannte im Café man sitzt, man plaudert, so "Reich mal.."
Das Café war voll aber es war still!
(Kiki: Traurig, ja!)
Die waren alle so am Smartphone und das hat mich wirklich sehr erschreckt!
Und ich selber mit mir war auch immer noch so unzufrieden.
Ich hab zwar meine Strafe verbüßt aber es haben viele Jugendliche immer auf mich hinauf geschaut.
Verherrlichend. Die haben gesehen diese tollen Autos, die ich gefahren bin
und ich komm in den Block reingefahren und alle: "Wow, wow!"
Ich hab das auch genossen zu dem Zeitpunkt damals.
Und dann bin ich rausgekommen und ich hab gemerkt bei diesen Jugendlichen: Es dreht sich nur noch um diese Thematik.
Dicke Autos, Modelabels, also schöne Modelabels. Uhren..
Ja? Und ich find das hat alles auch so an Wert verloren weil wir alle nur noch so danach prangern und streben.
So gewisse Werte sind voll verloren gegangen und ich hab dann für mich gesagt: "Pff..
Ich nehme wir das zu einer Mission. Ich weiß einige Kids mögen mich und die haben auf mich so hoch geschaut
und ich will denen so zeigen: "Ey, wir können auch anders cool sein!)
(Kiki: Ja, in Form von Kochen!)
In Form von Kochen, in Form von der Frau unter die Arme greifen oder der Mutter, der Schwester einfach mal unter die Arme greifen.
Und dass man damit auch cool sein kann und noch cooler sogar, ja?
Und hamdulilah so der Plan geht auf.
Und das gibt mir auch wiederum dann so meinen Seelenfrieden.
Was ich also damals an Drogen immer verkauft hab, das hat sehr viele Leute erreicht
und wie gesagt, das hat immer so ein bisschen..
(Kiki: An dir genagt?)
(Sharo: Ja [..])
Und die Leute haben dich ja auch damals eher so auf deine materiellen Güter richtig druntergestuft
(Sharo: Genau, genau!)
Oder eher im Gegenteil hochgestuft. Und jetzt bist du der Sharo mit Charakter, mit Herzblut.. Und ich sehe auch -
Guck mal, wenn ich dich sehe - Ist leider Fakt Leute, man hat immer Vorurteile!
Wenn ich dich auf der Straße sehen würde..
(Sharo: Du würdest die Straßenseite wechseln!)
Würd ich sagen:"Boah, den darf ich nicht schief angucken, sonst.."
Leider! Leider, auch mir gegenüber haben die Leute Vorurteile. Aber dann stehst du hier:
So ein reines Herz! Man merkt das, man merkt's auch in den Videos.
(Sharo: Danke!)
So viel kann man gar nicht faken! Also so viel kann man gar nicht faken!
Manchmal machst du so einen Gorilla-Emoji ist mir aufgefallen mit 'nem Herzen!
(Sharo: Das ist mein Lieblingsemoji!)
Das spiegelt dich auch richtig wider!
So ein Gorilla aber mit 'nem Riesenherz!
Also ist echt so!
(Sharo: Danke Kiki!)
Und deswegen ja, richtig cool, dass wir zusammengetroffen haben nochmal!
Und wir haben uns grade auch was Cooles für euch überlegt weil du bist ja immer noch sehr im Bereich Fitness.
Das ist ja deine zweite Leidenschaft sage ich mal neben Kochen.
(Sharo: Absolut!)
Da haben wir uns überlegt machen wir gleich ein cooles Homeworkout. Grad für alle, die Zuhause bleiben müssen,
Fitnessstudios haben geschlossen..
(Sharo: Absolut, ich hab ein richtig knackiges Programm für euch!)
Geil! Und Hamza macht dann hoffentlich auch mit!
Hamza?
(Hamza: Ich muss mitmachen!)
Tristan kann die Cam halten!
(Tristan: *lacht* Okay!)
So, genau. Wir braten jetzt die Burger an.
Wie gesagt: Ohne Fett, von beiden Seiten.
Und salzen und pfeffern auch danach erst, ne?
So, hau die Burger ruhig drauf!
(Sharo: Pfanne schon heiß?)
Schon heiß, ja!
Das geht ruck-zuck bei dir hier!
(Kiki: *lacht* Ja!)
Wir machen direkt mehrere, ja?
Auf jeden Fall, ja!
(Sharo: Ohh!)
Dieser Beef-Duft, ich liebe das immer wieder!
Riecht jetzt schon richtig geil!
Ich liebe das!
Sollen wir uns einparfümieren damit's bleibt?
Das wär 'ne Idee, so ein Parfum davon, ne? Beef!
(Kiki: Ja, gibt's noch nicht!)
Beef for men!
*alle lachen*
Meinen Wender für gleich..
(Sharo: Oh, der ist auch von Kiki!)
Der ist auch von mir, ja! Darf der bei dir noch ein bisschen rot sein innen?
(Sharo: Absolut!)
Ja?
(Sharo: Wie stehst du zu rohem Fleisch?)
Find ich jetzt nicht schlimm aber..muss auch nicht sein!
Nee?
(Kiki: Aber heute ess ich's auch!)
Kennst du Kibbeh?
(Kiki: Ja!)
Roh?
Roh nein! Ich kenn das nur - also im Türkischen ist das Içli Köfte. Und da ist das richtig durch, durch, durch!
Ich mein aber bei uns gibt's auch nochmal Kibbeh roh.
(Kiki: Ach nein, du meinst - genau!)
Kibbeh Nayeh!
Boah, ich könnt dafür..
(Kiki: Echt?!)
Voll geil! Wie ist das mit dir Hamza?
(Hamza: Ich mag das auch nicht!)
(Kiki: Wir sind Weicheier!)
Nein? Da sind Minze unt Pistazien obendrüber - Traum!
Sollen wir ein paar Tomaten..?
(Sharo: Tomaten..)
Oder ist das zu wässrig?
Also bei mir war mal Ali Bumaye zu Gast bei Beast Kitchen. Und ich hab auch immer meinen Burger wirklich mit Tomate gerne gegessen.
Und er hat gesagt: "Nein! Auf einen guten Burger gehört keine Tomate drauf!"
Warum? Das wird sonst zu matschig. Er darf ein bisschen matschig sein aber auch nicht zu matschig.
Ich hab mir diesen Tipp zu Herzen genommen und er hat absolut recht!
Okay, weißt du was? Dann Ciao! Weg damit, keine Tomaten!
Wir können aber ein bisschen frische Gurken!
Ja! Du kannst wenn du möchtest den Camembert auch schon dazu geben.
Hier auf die Burger, ne?
(Kiki: Ja!)
Wir haben auch noch den panierten Camembert, war Hamzas Idee.
Für die nächsten Burger können wir auch den panierten nehmen.
Magst du Camembert an sich?
Ich muss dir gestehen: Ich bin kein Fan davon!
Ja dann lass mal weg!
(Sharo: Nee, nee, ich ess!)
Ich ess das aber ich bin kein Fan davon!
(Kiki: Kein Riesen Fan davon?)
Aber wenn ich jetzt die Wahl hätte: Camembert oder keinen? Dann würde ich sagen "Nee!"
Soll ich dir mal ganz ehrlich was sagen? Ich bin auch kein großer Fan davon!
(Sharo: Warum - *lacht*)
Aber ich dachte: "Komm, ausgefallen! Camembert, Preiselbeeren ist doch fancy!
(Sharo: Ist geil! Okay, machen wir! Preiselbeeren hast du auch schon probiert?)
(Kiki: Preiselbeeren find ich lecker, ja! So in Torten!)
Ich hab das als wir in Holland waren das erste Mal gegessen!
(Kiki: Ach frische meinst du?)
Nee, genau so!
(Kiki: So, ja?)
Nee, bei Beast Kitchen war das! Das war bei Beast Kitchen, wo ich das das erste Mal gegessen hab! Mit dem Hähnchenschnitzel - mit dem Kalbsschnitzel!
Also wird mal Zeit, dass ihr uns einladet! Das hört sich gut an, ne?
Sieht echt knackig aus! Das liegt echt an dem heißen Wasser, ne?
Ja, heißes Wasser löst die Stärke besser! Klar, mit kaltem Wasser löst du auch etwas Stärke oder spülst du etwas Stärke mit raus
aber mit heißem löst du die richtig, da geht richtig viel raus!
(Kiki: Ja, da merkst du richtig den Unterschied!)
Und Stärke ist auch das, was uns überwiegend dick macht!
(Kiki: Ja?)
(Sharo: Ja!)
Deshalb achtes du so auf..
Was beachtest du bei deiner Ernährung. machst du Low Carb hin und wieder oder..?
Nein, nein, nein, nein!
Ich sag immer wieder man soll sich gesund und vollwertig ernähren.
Wir brauchen von allem etwas!
Low Carb ist okay, kannst du mal machen
aber wenn ich höre: "Ja, ich bin seit halbem Jahr Low Carb", dann sage ich dir: "Nein Fräulein, das ist falsch!"
(Kiki: Man muss die Reserven irgendwann wieder auffüllen?)
Genau!
Auch um deinen Stoffwechsel wieder anzukurbeln, ja? Auf Low Carb fährt ja dein Stoffwechsel komplett runter, ja?
Und wir brauchen auch Kohlenhydrate. Wenn du morgens deine Kohlenhydrate isst -
Sagen wir, du hast einen klassischen Tag: Du stehst morgens auf, gehst abends ins Bett.
Da kann ich euch wirklich nur empfehlen: Steht auf und morgens schon eure Kohlenhydrate zu euch nehmen. Wieso?
Du hast die ganze Nacht nichts gegessen, dein Körper braucht die Energie. Du brauchst auch die Energie, um den ganzen Tag zu gestalten.
Du gehst zur Arbeit, du willst aktiv sein.
Manche sagen: "Ich frühstücke erst um 12 Uhr."
Auch vollkommen falsch!
(Kiki: Nein, das geht auch nicht!)
(Kiki: Da bist du doch dann irgendwann - da isst du um 12h und dann-)
Da hast du auch direkt ein Mittagessen meistens und dann hast du wieder nichts gegessen bis zum späten Abend.
Dann nochmal vorm Schlafen ne Pizza bestellt oder ne Pizza aufgewärmt..
und dann legt man sich hin. Und dann hast du so viel überflüssige Energie abends zu dir genommen,
die wir nicht mal verbrennen können und die über Nacht dann ansetzt.
Von daher sage ich wirklich immer wieder: Gesund und vollwertig ernähren
und die Kohlenhydrate immer zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt.
Grad der bestimmte Zeitpunkt wäre jetzt wie gesagt morgens, mittags
und zum Abend hin wenn der Tag ausklingt, brauchst du auch keine Kohlenhydrate mehr.
Da kannst du ne Avocado mit bisschen Feta bearbeiten oder Nüsse und Salat..
Ein Thunfischsalat, ein Rührei ohne Brot! Und dann kannst du wunderbar..
(Kiki: Rührei abends bin ich voll der Fan von! Wir machen uns abends immer so geiles Rührei..)
(Kiki: Da braucht man auch gar kein Brot, das sättigt dich ja!)
Genau, richtig! Das sättigt und..probiert's aus! Low Carb halte ich nix von.
Ich muss ehrlich gesagt gestehen: Anfang des Jahres habe ich Low Carb gemacht ein paar Wochen. Ich hab mich dann auch voll fit gefühlt
und irgendwann ey, ich hab Brot vermisst, ich hab ein bisschen Reis vermisst, gerade türkische Küche..
Dein Stoffwechsel fährt ja euch extrem runter dadurch.
Irgendwann mal nach einer Zeit nimmst du nicht mehr ab und dann fragen sich die Frauen immer:
"Oh mein Gott, ich tu und da tut sich nix mehr obwohl ich Low Carb ernähre!" und da ist der Fehler!
(Hamza: Also sagst du quasi Low Carb eher abends als morgens?)
Ja safe! Es hängt davon ab, was du beruflich machst.
Wenn du jetzt abends eine Nachtschicht hast, kann ich dir empfehlen, dann abends Kohlenhydrate zu dir zu nehmen
weil du die Nacht ja beschäftigt bist.
(Kiki:  Klar, das klingt auch wieder logisch!)
Unser Hirn arbeitet ja immer hauptsächlich über Glukose.
Und das ist ja so die andere - Kohlenhydrate nehmen wir zu uns, der Körper wandelt das um zu Glukose und dadurch arbeitet dein Gehirn dann.
Wir brauchen Kohlenhydrate!
(Kiki: Das klingt so logisch wenn du's so erklärst aber dann hört man..)
Ist es ja auch, ist es ja auch!
Ihr dürft nicht vergessen: Viele wollen immer was anpreisen und was verkaufen.
Ich verteufel nicht Low Carb, ja? Low Carb ist gut.
Aber maximal, wirklich maximal 6 Wochen danach musst du raus aus deiner Low Carb Phase.
Low Carb kommt eigentlich aus dem Bodybuilding.
Wie kommt das, was will man dann erreichen?
Du schrumpfst ja ein, dass der Muskel sich zusammenzieht
dass du wirklich die letzten Fettecken verbrennen tust.
Und kurz bevor du dann auf die Bühne gehst, dann gibst du dir ja ganz viele Kohlenhydrate.
Dann saugen sich wieder deine Muskeln voll und dann präsentiert man sich ja.
(Kiki: Ach, okay. Machst du auch mit bei Wettkämpfen?)
Jaja!
(Kiki: Können wir da mal ein Bild von einblenden jetzt?)
(Sharo: Zack!)
(Hamza: Jetzt kommt Spongebob!)
(Hamza: Machst du eigentlich immernoch jetzt Wettkämpfe oder ist das jetzt so..?)
Ich bin da grad wirklich mit am kämpfen! Ich bin da wirklich mit am kämpfen.
Ich hab mir das immer als Traum vorgestellt, auf der Bühne zu stehen und gut abzuräumen. Das hab ich Gott sei Dank schon geschafft.
Natürlich ist der Kick für mich noch da, weiterzumachen. Will ich auch gerne, allerdings hält mich momentan mein Beruf davon ab.
Ja, willkommen in meinem Leben! Du meinst Beast Kitchen, ne? Willkommen in meinem Leben!
Ich habe seit Kikis Kitchen auch 6kg zugenommen.
Es ist sehr schwer, ja. Immer wieder hier probieren und nasch mal da und snack mal da.
(Hamza: Das wollt ich grad sagen!)
*lacht*
Bei so einer Diät für den Kraftsport oder Bodybuilding ist das ein No-Go. Da entscheidet schon ein Keks über Sieg oder Gewinn.
Aber das find ich auch krass, dass du das so - du nimmst das ja in Kauf, ne?
Du machst ja Beast Kitchen leidenschaftlich gerne und nimmst das total in Kauf, dass du dadurch halt Richtung Fitness hier und da mal einen Abstrich machen musst!
Ich pack das hier nochmal schön dazwischen, ne?
Ja, ich versuch immer, alles so unter einen Hut zu bekommen.
Das ist ja auch so ein - ich sag mal ein Erfolgsrezept von mir, ja?
Ich sag mal jetzt momentan stehen keine Wettkämpfe an, da kommt das Kochen, das Schlemmen zum Vordergrund.
Ich denk mal wenn ich später wieder mehr so in Richtung Wettkampfsvorbereitung gehe, wird das Sportliche mehr im Vordergrund stehen.
(Kiki: Klar!)
Ich bin mir aber ehrlich gesagt auch nicht sicher.
Ich weiß nicht, wo meine Reise mich hinführt. Ich will auch nicht so weit jetzt nach vorne schauen.
Ich setz mir immer lieber kleine Ziele.
Kleine Etappen in Form von 2-3 Monaten und dann gucken, wie sich das entwickelt.
(Kiki: Find ich auch super wichtig!)
Man weiß im Endeffekt eh nie, was passiert!
(Sharo: Genau!)
So, wir haben den Burger jetzt mehr oder weniger zusammengebaut!
(Sharo: Ich helf dir mal beim Belegen, tut mir leid Kiki!)
Ach alles gut! Wir wollten ja jetzt erstmal - genau, das hatt ich nämlich grade vergessen!
(Sharo: Ich hab das vergessen, tut mir leid!)
Alles gut!)
Jetzt kommt ein Salatblatt drauf.
(Kiki: Genau, ein Salatblatt!)
So, dann kommt ein Burger Patty..
So!
(Kiki: Mhm, jetzt die Preiselbeeren oder machst du erstmal..?)
Nö, Preiselbeeren und dann Gürkchen. Wolltest du Gurken haben?
(Kiki: Ja, wenn wir die schonmal geschnitten haben - wenn die noch drauf passen!)
(Kiki: Drunter mogeln!)
Locker!
(Kiki: Perfekt! So!)
(Sharo: Machen wir noch einen! Oh, der ist nicht angeröstet!)
Burger kommen viele Sachen drauf an! Die Größe: das ist perfekt!
Gewicht ist perfekt, Optik: mega!
Und bei Beast Kitchen sage ich immer: Bismillah und rein damit!
Bismillah!
Boah, geil! Mmmh!
Ich find das Süße so geil!
(Hamza: Sharo hat zu groß abgebissen! *lacht*)
Ich lass diese Geschmacksexplosion - von unten nach oben wirklich das fängt an
ich sag jetzt mal "Big Mac Soße" dazu oder "McDonald's Soße" - hat ne geile Note.
Und dann die frische Gurke. Ich weiß nicht, hast du die auch erwischt?
(Kiki: Hab ich erwischt, ja!)
Und dann diese Harmonie mit dem Fleisch, Käse, Preiselbeeren - mega!
Mein Highlight ist der Camembert obwohl ich am Anfang gedacht hab..
Dein Highlight ist der Camembert?
(Kiki: Ja!)
Ich sag dir, was mein Highlight ist: dein Brötchen!
Echt? Geil, Danke!
(Sharo: Mega geil, ich schwör's!)
Die ganze Kombi ist lecker!
Unbedingt nachmachen, ganz ehrlich!
Wenn ihr mal was anderes möchtet, nicht immer diesen klassischen Beef Burger,
dann macht unbedingt Camembert, Preiselbeeren und die berühmte Big Mac Soße!
McDonald's Soße!
(Kiki: McDonald's Soße, genau!
Oder Tristan Soße! Und dann haben wir hier noch die Fritten..
Mh, die hab ich noch gar nicht probiert!
Das gehört zu nem geilen Burger dazu!
(Kiki: Sehr lecker!)
Wir gönnen uns das jetzt erstmal. Wir geben den anderen auch noch ein bisschen was ab, ne?
Wem?
(Kiki: Den anderen beiden, oder?)
Weiß ich nicht!
(Kiki: Oder sollen wir einfach selber essen?)
Wir haben gleich noch Sport vor!
(Kiki: Stimmt!)
Erstmal gönnen wir uns!
(Kiki: Erstmal gönnen wir uns und die anderen können zusehen, ne?)
(Hamza: Sieht lecker aus auf jeden Fall!)
(Sharo: Mega lecker, wirklich!)
Ja, wir haben jetzt 'nen richtig fetten Burger gegessen,
Ofenkartoffeln gegessen, war richtig lecker!
Aber jetzt muss ich auch die Kalorien verbrennen Sharo! Was machen wir jetzt?
Genau! Dafür hab ich ein exaktes Programm für dich und ich denke auch für deine Community genau das Richtige.
Wir straffen hauptsächlich den Rumpf oder wir trainieren hauptsächlich den Rumpf und die Beine.
Dieses Programm: Du brauchst nicht viel Platz, wir brauchen keine Geräte.
Und das ist auch eine perfekte - das ist nicht nur eine Kraft-Ausdauer Übung sondern wir trainieren auch hier gleich die Koordination
was für den Alltag natürlich auch wichtig ist.
Ich sag mal wenn du 'nen Wäschekorb hast, du willst hier hoch gehen, dann muss ja auch ein bisschen Koordination sein.
Oder wenn die Damen in den Keller runter gehen oder hoch auf den Dachboden,
da ist Koordination auch im Alltag sehr wichtig und dieses Training eignet sich perfekt dafür.
Es besteht hauptsächlich eigentlich nur aus Ausfallschritten.
Ausfallschritte kennst du?
(Kiki: Ja!)
Springende Kniebeugen!
(Kiki: Springende Kniebeugen?)
Schon mal gehört?
(Kiki: Oh, ich erahne Böses!)
Mhm, das wird knackig! Das wird knackig!
(Kiki: Ja, okay!)
Wir können das Ganze gestalten:
Also wir machen gleich 4 Ausfallschritte nach vorne,
direkt ohne Pause 4 Ausfallschritte nach hinten
und dann 4 Ausfallschritte jeweils zur Seite.
Und direkt 4 mal springende Kniebeugen.
(Kiki: Okay!)
Das wäre der erste Satz. Dann können wir einmal durchschnaufen,
dann gehen wir hoch direkt auf 8 Wiederholungen
(Kiki: *lacht*)
Du hast gut gegessen, komm!
Wir können dann nochmal hochgehen auf 8 Wiederholungen
und wenn wir die 8 geschafft haben, gehen wir nochmal auf 12
und dann nochmal von 12, 8 auf 4 runter.
Okay, alles klar. Und du machst aber alles parallel mit mir mit?
(Sharo: Ich mach alles parallel mit dir mit.)
Wir feuern uns gegenseitig an!
(Kiki: Okay!)
(Hamza: San Sebastian ruft euch schon!)
Und der San Sebastian Kuchen, Käsetorte wartet noch auf uns!
(Kiki: Der wartet auch noch auf uns!)
Danach haben wir uns den verdient denke ich!
(Kiki: Okay, los geht's!)
So, wir müssen ein Stück weiter nach vorne weil wenn wir gleich die hinteren Ausfallschritte machen,
wir ziehen das direkt in einem durch!
(Kiki: Okay!)
Wie fit bist du auf 'ner Skala von 1-10? 10 ist das Beste.
Im Moment 4.
(Sharo: 4 im Moment?)
Ja!
(Sharo: Da müssen wir stark dran arbeiten!)
Ganz kurz: Damit wir die Koordination auch einarbeiten
wenn wir gleich den Ausfallschritt machen -
Wir machen einen Ausfallschritt und die Hände bleiben hier ungefähr auf Ohrenhöhe.
Und damit wir den Rumpf auch schön trainieren, drehen wir uns immer Richtung Standbein.
(Kiki: Okay, okay! Das heißt der ist vorne und dann drehe ich mich nach rechts!)
Genau und da ist dann gleich die Koordination gefragt! Wir trainieren gleichzeitig unser Hirn mit.
So, are you ready?
Yes!
(Sharo: Are you ready?)
(Kiki: Ich bin ready!)
Okay! 4 Ausfallschritte nach vorne!
Sehr schön! Und zurück, komm!
Nächstes Bein! So, merkt ihr schon?
Zweite..drei..
Zurück..und jetzt den vierten, komm!
4 nach hinten, wir sind noch nicht fertig. Komm, direkt in einem durch!
Eins!
2! Merkst du die Koordination!
(Kiki: Ja!)
Und 4, okay?
(Kiki: Man muss sich echt konzentrieren!)
Absolut! Wir sind noch nicht fertig, 4 Ausfallschritte zur Seite.
(Kiki: Okay!)
2 nach rechts, 2 nach links.
Okay, wir fangen mit rechts an.
Senken! Auf dein Standbein hoch..genau!
Sehr gut! Nochmal nach links.
Sie können ruhig mitmachen junge Dame!
So! Jetzt gehen wir in die Knie.
Und eins! Zwei!
(Kiki: So ganz synchron ist es noch nicht aber boah, ich muss schon sagen: Mir ist schon warm!)
Sehr gut! Jetzt machst du die nächsten 8!
Komm, ich achte auf deine Ausführung und auf deine Geschicklichkeit. Komm!
Koordination!
(Kiki: Also immer 8? Okay!)
Komm, 8! Ich feuer dich jetzt richtig an, Kiki! Wir gehen auch hoch auf 12
und von 12, 8, 4 mache ich direkt mit.
(Kiki: Okay, alles klar!)
Komm!
Eins, sehr schön!
(Kiki: Uaah!)
Ganz kurz, hast du gemerkt?
Du musst erst den Schritt machen. Wenn du dich erst gesenkt hast, dann drehst du dich!
(Kiki: Dann erst drehen, okay alles klar!)
Okay, komm!
(Kiki: Fangen wir 2 nochmal an!)
2, alles klar!)
Drei!
Vier!
Fünf! Komm, weiter!
(Kiki: Noch kann ich, ich bin nur langsam!)
Sechs!
Acht, genau!
Jetzt 4 Ausfallschritte nach hinten. Erst den Schritt setzen, senken, dann drehen!
(Kiki: Okay!)
Sehr schön! Eins!
Zwei..drei!
(Kiki: Bin ich dir zu langsam?)
Nee!
(Kiki: Sei ruhig ehrlich!)
Nein, ich bin ehrlich! Es geht nicht um Schnelligkeit!
(Kiki: Okay!)
Wichtig ist, dass wir hier die Übung sauber ausführen, dass die Technik sauber ist!
(Kiki: Okay! Hab mir 'ne Pause erschlichen!)
Vier..komm! Fünf..
Sechs, sehr schön!
(Kiki: Ah, sorry, sorry, sorry!)
Alles gut!
Merkst du, ne? Sieben!
(Kiki: Ja!)
Komm und noch einen! Vier - acht Ausfallschritte zur Seite!
(Kiki: Okay!)
Senken, hoch!
Das war falsch! Du weißt, was falsch war, ne?
(Kiki: Okay warte, nochmal!)
(Kiki: Äh so?)
Ja senken und mit dem Bein hoch!
Genau und jetzt links!
(Kiki: Jaja, dann tut das auch mehr weh!)
Genau, richtig!
(Kiki: Okay!)
Drei, komm! Vier, komm!
Fünf, komm! Easy!
Sieben, komm! Acht, komm!
8 springende Kniebeugen! Komm schon, ich mach mit!
(Kiki: Okay!)
Eins, zwei..sieben!
*beide lachen*
Alles gut?
(Kiki: Ja, alles gut! Ich bin voll aus der Übung!)
Wir sind nur am Bocken, wir sind nur am Kochen, nur am Essen und Sport bleibt immer so ein bisschen auf der Strecke bei uns.
Das hört sich so an, als wenn du jetzt aufgeben willst!
Nein nein, nein nein!
(Sharo: Okay, sehr gut!)
8 haben wir gemacht und jetzt kommen wir auf 12.
Und wenn ihr das Zuhause gestalten wollt und ihr seid bisschen fitter, könnt ihr dann im nächsten Schritt auf 16 gehen.
Von 16 auf 20, 24, 28, 32 und wieder runter. Geht! Kein Problem, du kannst das individuell gestalten.
(Kiki: Je fortgeschrittener man ist, umso mehr kann man dranhängen?)
Genau! Wenn du auch nicht so fit bist, machst du nur bis 8.
8 haben wir gemacht, jetzt kommt?
(Kiki: 12!)
Yallah! Attacke, komm!
(Kiki: los geht's!)
Ruhig! Es geht nicht um Schnelligkeit!
Okay, ein Schritt. Whoop!
Senken..aah!
Drehen. Ja? Zurück!
Komm! Sieben!
Alles gut Kiki?
(Kiki: Ja, noch, noch!)
Komm! Wie ein Uhrwerk läufst du grad!
Neun!
(Kiki: *lacht*)
Elf!
(Kiki: Oh jaja, sorry!)
(Kiki: So!)
Alles gut?
(Kiki: Alles gut!)
12 nach hinten!
(Kiki: Okay!)
Komm!
Eins! Ah, Koordination, merkste?
(Kiki: Ja, tschuldigung!)
Was war das denn?!
Du hättest dich doch einfach wegdrehen müssen!
*beide lachen*
(Kiki: Ich hatte das Knie - nein, ich hatte das Knie vorne!)
Genau, 12 nach hinten! Komm, von vorne!
(Kiki: Okay!)
Whoop, zurück! Nach rechts drehen!
Eins! Alles gut Kiki?
Mhm!
(Sharo: Ich hör nix mehr von dir!)
(Kiki: Nee, ich konzentriere mich!)
Fünf!
Okay, sehr gut! Sechs!
Sieben! Deine Schritte werden immer kleiner!
Wird wacklig jetzt, ne?
(Kiki: Okay, okay!)
Hey, deine Beine, alles okay?
(Kiki: Jaja, alles gut! Alles gut!)
Neun!
(Hamza: Ich glaub 3 sind zu viel!)
Ja!
Ey, die 3 ziehe ich jetzt noch durch! Das kann ich mit meinem Gewissen nicht vereinbaren, komm!
Neun..zurück!
(Sharo: Kämpfer!)
12! 12 zur Seite, wir sind noch nicht fertig.
Knallt rein, oder?
(Kiki: Ja, knallt richtig rein!)
Da siehst du mal wie unsportlich ich geworden bin!
Ja, ich denke..Probiert's aus Leute, kommentiert in den Kommentaren.
Unterschätzt das Ganze nicht, ehrlich!
(Kiki: Ehrlich!)
(Kiki: Es sieht einfach aus und ist mega schwer!)
Das ist ne mehrgelenkige Übung,
es arbeitet viel. Dein ganz Körper arbeitet, Hirn arbeitet, du verbrennst viele Kalorien.
Ist heftig. Man merkt's!
Bin schon richtig am Schwitzen, bei ihm ist noch alles trocken!
(Sharo: Komm, hopp hopp!)
(Kiki: Okay!)
12 zur Seite. Wir fangen mit rechts an, komm!
Eins, Standbein hochziehen. Whoop!
Guck mal, die macht sich gut!
Acht!
Kikiii! Sind wir Macher oder Kacker? 12!
(Kiki: Macher!)
Macher! Komm, in die Knie!
Hüftbreit stehen, sehr gut!
Und komm! Eins, zwei!
Elf, komm! Zwölf!
Sehr gut! Wir sind eigentlich noch nicht fertig!
(Kiki: Ich weiß!)
Jetzt müssen wir nochmal 12 machen, 8 machen, 4 machen, dann sind wir durch!
Sagen wir mal das war das Anfängertraining und wer fortgeschritten ist, kann jetzt noch weitermachen!
Alles gut?
(Kiki: Ja, alles gut!)
Ich hab schon lang keinen Sport mehr..
(Sharo: Ehrliche Meinung?)
Ehrlich? Hammer Training aber ich bin k.o. weil ich einfach lange
- also wenn, dann war ich in den letzten Wochen nur joggen aber das kannst du ja nicht vergleichen.
Aber so richtig Sportarten wie jetzt, also diese Übungen habe ich sehr lange nicht mehr, ist mindestens 1 Jahr her.
Und deswegen merke ich so: Die Muskelgruppen sind voll untrainiert gerade!
Also mit dieser Übung - garantiere ich dir wenn du das wirklich jeden 2.Tag machst -
kannst du auf jeden Fall Ergebnisse erzielen.
Bleibt am Ball. Du trainierst wirklich nicht nur deine Kraft, die Ausdauer. Du trainierst auch die Koordination.
Auf jeden Fall, ich hab's gemerkt! Bei mir muss so ein bisschen Übung ran aber..
(Sharo: Kein Problem! Du bist ganz schön aus der Puste jetzt, was?)
(Kiki: Ja, ich bin richtig k.o. gerade!)
Aber ich hab dich vorgewarnt, ich bin mega unsportlich!
(Sharo: Wir könnten das jetzt so machen:)
Du hältst die Cam, ich schnapp mir Hamza und mach die 12, 8, 4 mit Hamza!
(Hamza: Was?!)
(Kiki: Ja, super gerne! Ja, geil!)
Yallah habibi, ta3ala!(= Komm her mein Freund!)
Auf Bruder, komm!
(Hamza: Ich hab Jeans an!)
(Kiki: Dann zieh dich schnell um!
(Hamza: Nein!)
Hamza, wie geht's?
Ja...
Ich sehe schon mashallah, komm!
Ja man merkt, ne?
(Sharo: Fußball hast du gespielt?)
Welche Position?
(Hamza: Ich war eigentlich rechts Flügel!)
Ich war auch immer links außen.
(Hamza: Okay!)
Aber auf der Bank!
Ich war eigentlich - ich war schon aufm Platz!
(Sharo: Okay, auf jeden Fall hast du Bock!)
12 runter, 12 -
(Hamza: Aber ich hab ne Jeans an, ist das schlimm?)
Mach mal einen Ausfallschritt, ich sag dir gleich ob's schlimm ist.
Okay, ja.
(Sharo: Okay? Und dann wieder zurück.)
Okay geht klar.
(Sharo: Wir machen erstmal ohne Drehung, okay?)
Wir machen 12 nach vorne, 12 nach hinten, 12 zur Seite und 12 mal die springenden Kniebeugen dann bist du durch!
(Hamza: Okay..Als ob das jetzt wenig wäre!)
Mega breit stehen..genau! Und jetzt fangen wir nach vorne an.
(Hamza: Okay!)
Komm, 12!
(Hamza: Mit links oder rechts?)
Ist egal, Hauptsache du machst!
(Hamza: Einen gespart!)
Komm, eins!
(Hamza: Eins!)
Zurück, komm!
Zwei!
Drei!
(Hamza: Voll locker, voll locker! Weiß gar nicht, was du hast Kiki!)
Vier! Mach mal richtige Schritte, komm!
(Hamza: Mach ich doch, hier!)
Fünf!
Acht!
(Hamza: Da sehe ich jetzt voll gelangweilt aus, ne?)
Komm, neun!
Das wird gleich warm, komm!
Elf..Du bist doch gut im Sport. Ich weiß gar nicht, was du hast!
(Hamza: Bin ich ja auch!)
Zwölf!
Ich hab nur 1-2kg zugenommen.
(Sharo: Jetzt hast du 13 gemacht, sehr gut!)
*Hamza lacht*
Eins, zwei! Deine Koordination ist gut!
Drei!
(Hamza: Uiuiui! Ey, mach Auge Alter, hör auf!)
Normalerweise damit ihr eure Stabilität haltet am Besten nach einem Punkt fixieren!
Einen Punkt fixieren, ja.
Das mach ich auch immer, wenn ich den mache.
Wenn ich den mache, dann ziel ich immer auf einen Punkt.
Immer einen Punkt aussuchen, dann bleibst du immer stabil!
(Hamza: Das waren jetzt 7!)
7?
(Hamza: 6 oder 7, ich weiß es nicht!)
Komm, jetzt machen wir 8! Kiki will schon wieder mitmachen, ich seh das schon!
12!
(Hamza: Ich bin krass, ne?)
Mega geil! Komm!
*beide lachen*
12 zur Seite! Nach rechts..
Knie senken! Ah, richtig senken!
(Hamza: Jaja..!)
Hintern richtig senken!
(Hamza: Ich hab Jeans an!)
Okay und hoch! Eins!
So..zwei!
Gleich reißt die Hose Alter!
Sechs!
Du musst mit deinem Standbein hochziehen!
(Hamza: Ja, meine Jeans!)
Nee, du gehst ja runter! Du musst ja wieder hoch!
(Hamza: Achso..)
Guck mal! Whoop..und hier hoch!
Ach mit dem, jaja! So meinst du das!
Hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch!
Mach mal den Schritt. Und hier kommst du jetzt hoch! Komm!
Ach, von hier hoch!
Ja!
(Hamza: Achso, jetzt zieht's!)
*Hamza lacht*
Da hoch, da hoch! Zehn, genau!
Zwölf! Komm, direkt in die Knie! In die Knie!
Hüftbreit stehen! Geh runter und komm! Eins, zwei..
(Kiki: Das ist eklig, ne?)
(Hamza: Ja, das ist eklig!)
Zwölf!
Aber eigentlich trainiere ich keine Beine!
Warum nicht?
Weil man die im Club nicht sieht! Nein Spaß!
(Sharo: Jaja, vor allem UNVERSTÄNDLICH! Grüße gehen raus!)
Du hast dich tapfer geschlagen!
(Hamza: Also besser als Kiki willst du sagen, ne?)
Nee...nee!
Aber vielleicht könnt's an der Jeanshose gelegen haben!
Ja auf jeden Fall!
Also ich bin ja so..Fitness so..
Können wir auch noch machen, hab ich auch noch tolle Übungen!
(Hamza: Aber hab ich keinen Bock!)
(Sharo: Hab ich mir schon gedacht!)
Also ich hab mir den San Sebastian verdient!
Auf jeden Fall!
(Sharo: Absolut!)
Einmal in die Kommentare: Klatschen für Hamza bitte!
(Kiki: Oh warte, die Kamera geht nicht!)
Ja ich bin richtig k.o., ich musste mich grad kurz sammeln!
Und Hamza hat sein Ding aber auch echt gut gemacht muss ich sagen!
Ihr habt das beide super gemacht, ehrlich!
Du bist lieb, dass du so lieb lügst!
Nein, nein, nein! Das werden die Leute auch in den Kommentaren bestätigen, ihr habt das wirklich super gemacht!
Ich hoffe ihr behaltet das bei!
Auf jeden Fall, ich mach's jetzt alle 2 Tage!
Perfekt, ich bin gespannt!
Und ich hoffe auch die Community macht das nach!
(Kiki: Auf jeden Fall!)
Das ist wirklich das perfekte Programm für die Damen, ja? Bauch, Beine, Po!
Oder auch ihr Kerle könnt das auch machen, auch in der Diskothek sehen wir die Beine!
Ja und bleibt mal am Ball!
(Kiki: Ja!)
Und die Koordination trainieren wir auch, das ist auch wichtig für den Alltag!
(Kiki: Auf jeden Fall! Danke fürs Zeigen, Sharo!)
Gerne!
Danke für den Tag heute!
(Sharo: Ich hab zu danken, Danke für eure Gastfreundschaft!)
(Kiki: Sehr, sehr gerne!)
Ich hab mich wirklich sehr wohl gefühlt!
Der Tristan auch, der ist schon fast eingepennt glaub ich auf der Couch!
Hat auf jeden Fall Spaß gemacht! Wir hoffen, euch hat das Video auch Spaß gemacht!
Checkt wie gesagt seine Kanäle ab, stehen unten in der Infobox!
Bei 200k ab mit dem Fahrrad nach Berlin!
Da darfst du auch noch mit, hast du nicht vergessen, ne?
(Kiki: Hab ich nicht - werd ich nicht vergessen!)
Ganz viel Spaß beim Nachmachen der Übungen, beim Nachmachen des Burgers
und jetzt Sharo kommt unsere schöne Verabschiedung!
Ein imaginärer..ich weiß selber nicht, was es ist!
Macht's gut!
(Sharo: Namaste!)
Ja, das ist auch geil!
Ciao, bis zum nächsten Mal! Tschüss!
(Sharo: Ciao ciao!)